and Ruger and Rajan joins me now from
Chicago to discuss this and more
professor Rajan so you talk about the
three pillars and suggest the third
pillar of civil society of communities
has been weakened what's your top remedy
for that well I think we need to push
bar back to the community over time as
markets have strengthened government has
also expanded but it's pulled power away
from the community to the national level
and from the national level to the
international level so as to govern
international markets I think what we
see with the weakening community is
partly the community itself needs to be
strengthened through direct measures but
also more empowerment of the community
will give a greater sense of engagement
and allow people to work towards the
better health of the community that
means pushing power from the
international to the national national
to regional regional to the community
level
professor Raja I want to talk about
India what are the lessons in the book
for India well India is a flourishing
democracy that's to its strengths it has
the preconditions for becoming a liberal
market society it has two problems one
it has a relatively weak government in
the sense of capabilities India needs to
do far more in becoming a middle-income
countries such as building out
infrastructure and that requires
stronger government it also has a
relatively weak private sector which is
often dependent on the government for
favors so India always has the
possibility of turning more
authoritarian coming to the elections I
think the elections that face India are
really about making choices in these
directions do we want a stronger economy
a more liberal economy which can also in
some ways making there much more of a
flourishing democracy or do we want a
more authoritarian structure and how do
you think it will play out in the ballot
box just looking at the conversation
nationally going on there over the last
few months well I think the Khan
session was about the economics of
Indian growth the lack of jobs for
example was a big issue till a few weeks
back since then there's been a
cross-border skirmish with Pakistan and
issues of national security have also
come on the plate
and my sense is as we go into the
elections all these issues jobs national
security but also how much respect
government has for the various
institutions we have such as the Reserve
Bank the Central Bureau of Investigation
all these issues will be debated and the
attitude of the government in power as
well as the attitude of the opposition
will become big factors in how the
voting goes well once the election is
over and once the new politicians are in
power what do they really need to do
what do you think they need to do and
that they can do well I think India like
many other countries including the
countries of the industrial West need to
really think about the distribution of
power within the country in the West we
see a great dissatisfaction with bar
having migrated outside the country into
the international arena but even within
country as for example in in the UK
there's a lot of concern in the north of
England that too much power is there in
London
I think Germany is different because
right from World War two there's been
more decentralization but you hear some
some murmurs even in Germany I think you
have a similar issue in India that there
is a sense that the states want more
freedom from the center more freedom to
determine policy and within the states
the localities the municipality is the
villages they want in a sense more
autonomy but also more funding they want
more of the tax revenues to devolve down
to them so that people have more of a
sense of participation in democracy to
my mind this is the biggest issue facing
the world going forward how much do we
allow people a sense that they have
command over their futures in the face
of tremendous technological change that
they have to essentially adapt to this
is as you talk about a global
phenomenon and I want to take a further
step back away from India now and ask is
the problem capitalism or more the kind
of capitalism the world has adopted in
recent decades it's not so much the kind
of capitalism or even capitalism itself
is the fact that capitalism every so
often has to adapt to serious
technological change in in our case now
it's the advent of our talent
intelligence the ability to communicate
tremendous distances which allows us to
create global supply chains all of which
have an impact on the kind of jobs that
are being created but also on the
sustainability of existing jobs
adaptation requires both the markets to
change but importantly the government as
well as the community to change for
example in the United States you need a
lot more people with strong high school
education but also perhaps education at
the level of the Community College now
the education system is not working it's
failing people at an early level so that
by the time they graduate from high
school they simply do not have the
skills that would be required of
somebody who ordinarily graduates so
this is really the problem we need to
adapt to technological change it's not
so much the system which has changed
Raghuram Rajan thank you his latest book
is the third pillar how markets and the
state leave the community behind